missing movies crime spree and some
surprise woodworking this is what Aviva
Bowman has been up to since she played
Nicola in Superbad Aviva Bowman's resume
was pretty thin before super bad after
background roles in the 1993 TV
miniseries the fireex time the 1994 film
troublemakers and a 2005 episode of
Malcolm in the Middle she landed the
supporting role of Caroline Franklin in
the 2006 religiously themed black comedy
forgiving the Franklin after that movie
debuted at the Sundance Film Festival
she was named an actor to watch by
Premier magazine one year later after a
few more one-off gigs Balman was tapped
by Seth Rogan and Evan Goldberg to play
foreign exchange student Nicola in
Superbad the fact that her first major
movie ended up being both a critical hit
and a box office smash was a stroke of
sheer luck and Balman was ready to keep
her momentum Rolling Along after super
bad Balman lands at a gig that couldn't
have been further removed from that
runchy teen comedy in 2008 she guest
starred on an episode of the
long-running CBS crime series Criminal
Minds in season 3's The Crossing Balman
played Sarah Henson a young girl whose
Mother Audrey confesses to murdering her
father though Audrey claims that she's
been abused by her husband and that she
killed him in self-defense Sarah
challenges that by asserting that her
dad was essentially their primary
caregiver she further alleges that it
was likely that her mother was actually
abusing her father and not the other way
around she was jealous that he loved us
more than her this account is verified
by Sarah's brother but is also slightly
Complicated by the fact that Sarah is
the beneficiary of her father's life
insurance policy Audrey eventually does
admit that her husband hadn't been
abusive after all and that she killed
him out of a bizarre sense of jealousy
toward his relationship with their kids
from a distance the only interesting
thing about the movie spring break 83 is
that it was never released it was
reportedly made and marketed in 2007 yet
it was only screened to one small
audience in 2009 then despite a
projected 2010 release State spring
break 83 just vanished but once you dig
into the star power behind this project
its disappearance becomes a lot stranger
the rest of the cast included such
notable names as Morgan Fairchild Joe
Pantano Eric Estrada and Lee Majors John
Goodman and Jamie Kennedy also appear in
the film's trailer although it's not
listed on either of their IMDb Pages as
of 2023 spring break 83 still hasn't
gotten anywhere close to a wide
theatrical release so it's probably safe
to say at this point that will never
receive one it's a shame that one of
Bowman's largest roles will never see
the light of day though maybe that's for
the best considering the tortured fact
story we're inclined to speculate that
it's probably not exactly the best movie
ever made in 2009 aiva Balman returned
to the indie film scene though this time
under slightly different circumstances
whereas 2006's forgiving the Franklin
was a dark comedy with a cast of largely
unknown actors St John of Las Vegas was
a star studed Affair that ended with a
disast debut starring John Cho Peter
Dinklage Romany Malco Tim Blake Nelson
Sarah Silverman Danny tro and Steve bumi
as the title character St John of Las
Vegas focuses on a recovering gambling
addict whose attempts to better himself
by fleeing Sin City ultimately sent him
back down the same troubled path Balman
plays Penny whom John meets while hiding
out in Albuquerque St John of Las Vegas
had a firsttime writer director in the
form of Hugh rhods a business developer
who had previously worked on only two
short films though had all the makings
of a successful Indie darling the movie
was immediately panned by critics upon
release my name is John and I am not
lucky after St John of Las Vegas flopped
Balman returned to a familiar genre the
police procedural by this point in her
career she'd established herself as a
reliable believable choice to play the
daughter of someone involved in a crime
and that was exactly what she did when
she guest starred on a season 5 episode
of the TNT Drama the closer starring
Kira Sedwick in the lead role the closer
offered a twist on the procedural
formula by focusing on the process of
closing a suspect this means getting
them to confess to the crime that the
evidence says they committed
unfortunately for Bowman the episode she
appeared in entitled alision Fields
didn't give her very much to do however
she would soon get the chance to play a
meteor character on a similar show the
gruffy stoic crime fighter is one of the
most recognizable tropes of the police
procedural formula one of the most
famous examples is Special Agent lero
Gibbs played by Mark Harman for 19
seasons on cbs's NCIS gibbs's backstory
is unique in its maob tragedy his wife
and young daughter were killed in a car
crash orchestrated by a drug dealer aiva
Bowman had a recurring role on NCIS as a
young Shannon Gibbs she appeared in
flashbacks in the season 6 episode
Heartland the season 7 episode Mother's
Day and the season 9 episode life before
his eyes this role was essentially
Bowman's first opportunity after super
bad to establish herself with a new
audience over time this sort of gig is a
huge milestone for any actor and
although it's been over a decade since
Bowman's last appearance on NCIS she's
remained busy in the time since we could
sit together I don't know it's a long
ride after a rockus and well-reviewed
first season in 2009 the Stars sitcom
party down was renewed for a second goor
round the show followed a group of
aspiring actors and writers in Los
Angeles who make ends Me by working for
a catering company in an era before
viewers were fully saturated in shows
sterzing the entertainment industry
party downturn the all too common day
job of catering into a hilarious series
of Misadventures the cast included the
likes of Adam Scott Jane Lynch Martin
star Lizzie Kaplan Megan mul and
Jennifer kulage and in a rare starring
role Ken Marino played Ron Donald the
team leader of the catering crew Aviva
Balman also showed up in a couple of
season 2 episodes as Ron's girlfriend
Mandy sadly for party down critical
Prestige couldn't quite make up for low
viewership it also didn't help that Jane
Lynch and Adam Scott were becoming busy
regulars on network TV shows
specifically Glee and Parks and
Recreation respectively and so party
down was cancelled before Balman could
become a series regular the show was
actually resurrected in 2023 though
Balman has yet to return to it in any
capacity once again a disappointing end
for Aviva Balman was followed by another
guest star turn on a procedural in 2010
after her time on party down wrapped up
she appeared on the Law and Order Los
Angeles episode Hondo field once again
she played someone related to a person
involved in a violent crime the episode
kicks off with an oil worker named
Freddy Ramirez being found dead on the
beach the LAPD detectives on the case
must then question those who worked with
Freddy on a dangerous oil rig they
eventually meet his mother Lucy a maid
who has worked for the casden family for
several years Bowman's character
Stephanie casden grew up with Freddy and
thought of him as a brother my parents
they don't know about Freddy and me I
never told them unfortunately Bowman's
Law and Order stint was similar to her
time on the closer in so far far as it
didn't really showcase her full
potential but that's the reality of
being a working actor in Hollywood
sometimes you take parts that aren't the
biggest deal because you need to keep
busy or get a paycheck so while Bowman's
time in the Dick Wolf Universe wasn't
exactly as iconic as super bad it didn't
hold her back from the next chapter in
her acting Journey after bouncing
between supporting Parts in comedies and
grieving daughters and police
procedurals aiva Balman landed a meaty
rooll on a season 5 episode of the USA
spy drama for notice the episode episod
was called No Good Deed and she made
quite the impression in a villainous
role the plot features the show's main
character ex CIA special agent Michael
Weston and his partner Max as they work
with an arms liaison named Fiona and
retired Navy SEAL Sam Axe to hunt down
the criminal mastermind behind a string
of robberies this Mastermind turns out
to be Bowman's character a woman named
Eve what do you want Baxter yeah nice to
meet
you yeah all right after an intense cat
and mouse game Michael outman Maneuvers
Eve by shaking her confidence in her
employer when she attempts to go into
hiding she's caught off guard by one of
Fiona's explosives even though Eve meets
a definitive End by the end of the
episode Balman still made the most of
the chances to show off her range alas
her opportunities for doing so have been
few and far between since then short
films don't typically raise the profiles
of their actors very often nevertheless
they can be great opportunities to
stretch creatively so while aiva Balman
may have been struggling with pretty
similar characters in her most prominent
projects she's consistently gone out of
her Comfort Zone in numerous short films
throughout her career even before super
bad she had roles in interesting shorts
like desperate hippies a comedy that
followed four Suburban Stoner chicks are
you smoking pots Bowman's other short
film credits include the offbeat Joy
Ride waffles for breakfast the juggler
which also starred Gossip Girl and you
star pen Badgley false Creek stories
which was narrated by Avatar star Steven
Lang the Sci-Fi comedy Earthbound and
the parody taken through three back to
normal though shorts aren't exactly a
typical path to start them Bowman's
consistent work making them demonstrates
her commitment to the independent side
of filmmaking early in her career Aviva
Balman was frequently credited as just
Aviva or with her maen name of Farber
she didn't become known as Aviva Balman
until 2012 which was when she married
fellow actor Ken Balman as it turns out
Ken Balman had a very similar career
trajectory as his wife he appeared in
several shorts and indy flicks before
landing what would become his career to
ing role in the teen drama series The
Secret Life of the American Teenager he
played Ben a high school student whose
girlfriend Amy played by shayene Woodley
becomes pregnant it isn't publicly known
when Ken and aiva began dating though
it's worth noting that he was also cast
in The ill- Faded spring break 83 their
relationship has been largely private
although it is known that they tied the
knot at a quiet ceremony in Malibu
California shortly afterwards he was
diagnosed with crohn's disease a chronic
inflammation that can cause severe
digestive symptoms he retired from
acting in 2013 his wife also retired
that same year although she's also
revealed that she wanted to leave Los
Angeles and returned to her hometown of
Santa Fe New Mexico Ken and Aviva Balman
have managed to keep their personal
lives private since retiring while also
keeping busy he began writing books
including a poetry collection called eat
the flowers an in-depth analysis of the
video game Earthbound and a novel called
stay cut map Aviva meanwhile founded a
jewelry company called twig works
working out of their Santa Fe home Aviva
utilizes her Lifelong Love of
woodworking to craft Earrings made of
salvaged wood and other recycled
materials according to Twig works'
website Aviva aims to highlight the
simple and fractal expressions of wood
in all its varieties through jewelry
that restores the feeling of being
playful and rooted since October 2016
twig Works has been featured in a few
local magazines and a via's woodworking
prowess isn't limited to earrings as
she's also made bolo ties cabinets
artisanal shelves and LGE wooden wall
art
pieces